germany is struggling to cope with a
surge of covid19 infections
despite being in a soft lockdown for
five months the number of cases is going
up
and hospitals say they're being pushed
to the limit today the cabinet here in
berlin agreed to approve
new national measures to try to bring
down infection rates
these new measures require a change in
the law to allow what is being called
an emergency break to be imposed in all
parts of the country if certain
conditions are met
now this new law would oblige all
regions to implement this
emergency break if there are more than
100 cova cases
per 100 000 people in a seven day period
then
a curfew would be imposed between the
hours of 9 p.m
and 5 a.m and then all non-essential
shops
would also be closed
chancellor angela merkel welcomed what
she called the urgently needed decision
by the government in order to improve
the situation and to slow down the third
wave
to break it and turn it around the
measures implemented thus far by the
state and regions don't go far enough
our response to the pandemic must be
more stringent and consequential
consequently
let's bring in our chief political
editor michelle kufner who is standing
outside of the chancellery
chancellory for us mr ella you were
listening into the chancellor's message
tell us more about
what you had to say well she basically
called this step of now
implementing a national um drive a
national emergency break
as a long overdue as setting the corona
fight
on a new footing and what that means is
that angela marco
took germany's corona response next
level
instead of continuing to gather the 16
state premiers around her
getting an agreed paper and then
everybody going
into their federal state and doing
whatever they like pretty much
she's now making this legally binding
well she doesn't mean that she can do it
alone she still
needs that signature on the dotted line
by enough mps she's taking this
to parliament and she's getting the
states to agree to it and that would
then make it legally binding
and there would be an immediate
emergency break implemented at that
magic figure of 100 infections for 100
000 people within the space of seven
days and that already applies to pretty
much
most of the country why is this question
of taking a national approach so
controversial
because there was a lot of credibility
lost when state premiers didn't stick to
what they
said and kept carving out exceptions for
their own states that has created a lot
of confusion that has cost
everybody a lot of public trust who
works in public policy
and that is also to blame for angela
mackel's own party dipping
in the opinion polls and these latest
infection rates going up once again we
are in the midst of that third wave here
in germany
and a majority of germans is actually
for a tougher
lockdown and if you ask people on the
street they certainly want to know
which rules apply wherever they go
and not on a 100 kilometer drive have
three different sets of regulations
apply
you said that the chancellor will have
to take this new law to parliament what
kind of support will she have for it
there
well it looks like she is getting enough
support to
take it to parliament the big question
now is will it be fast track
can this all be decided this week the
parliamentary groups
are currently meeting as we speak here
so still
more intense debates to be had but this
looks like it's
definitely going ahead in germany with
experts warning hospitals warning that
it's simply
coming too late angela mackel herself
said
if we i said a long time ago she said if
we wait
until those intensive care beds are
filling up
and are full then it's too late and
germany is pretty much nearing that
point right now
our chief political editor michele
lacuna with the latest thank you
now aerosol researchers are criticizing
coronavirus measures and they are
calling for a radical rethink they say
infections
outside hardly take place and we can
speak now to christoph aspak he's the
president of the society for aerosol
research he's taken
part in this research thank you very
much for joining us
now tell us what the research shows
about how covid
is being transmitted what are the
findings here
well first of all we know we have known
for several months already that it's
mostly an aerosol transmission so
airborne transmission of the virus
um and at the same time we know that
aerosols or aerosol particles as we
exhale them they're quickly diluted when
you're outdoors because there are always
wind
currents there's always a thermal motion
upwards
and that quickly dilutes the virus
concentration and therefore it's very
unlikely that you
get infected outdoors whereas indoors
it's much more likely because the virus
concentration can
accumulate and there has been a recent
study published in ireland
and they checked more than 230 000
infections and they found that 99.9
of them actually occurred indoors and
that's
what we try to make sure that everyone
understands and also the general public
that
it's the most the highest infection risk
is actually indoors and not outdoors
so you're saying basically the measures
that are currently in place they don't
prevent infection they might even
be counterproductive so which measures
would that be that they don't help
really
well what we criticize is that there's
two
too large focus on measures for outdoors
whereas outdoors not nothing really or
almost no infections occur
these include the duty to wear a mask
when you're outdoors that several places
which are very popular are locked
like along the rhine river for example
here in in my area
and that doesn't really help because we
should focus a lot more on the indoor
infections and that applies
to well all indoor environments that
includes
private homes that includes workplaces
that includes shops that includes public
transport and so on and
that that's what we try to bring along
that it's really the the indoor
environment where it can get critical
okay so what measures would you
recommend to the government to take
right now
if you could advise them
well i mean several measures are already
taken when it comes to public transport
and it's really
um critical that
these are checked and make sure that
people
really follow these rules and
it's not only the government but it's
also the media and
and just the general public that needs
to understand that you need to be
careful indoors
and there are several very simple
measures and i don't
uh really think that you need a law or
anything to enforce that
because what people should do is open
windows
and exchange the air that is indoors
whenever possible
so when the the the weather is fine just
leave the window open
all day basically wear masks whenever
you meet people
use air cleaning devices to
reduce the the virus concentration and
most importantly limit the number of
contacts
indoors outdoors it doesn't really count
but indoors limit the number of contacts
and limit the time that you meet these
people indoors and
these are the most important things to
to keep in mind and
that can help to to reduce the
infections i'm wondering you said
you know a lot of this research has been
around for some time now we know
that infections are spreading more
indoors far more indoors than really
outdoors
why do you think that hasn't enough
really been informing the policy that's
been taken
well that's a very difficult question
and i think it goes
beyond what i can judge as an aerosol
scientist because i think it has very
lot of political reasons and it's
probably easier to control
outdoors if people are not gathering and
people are really
wearing masks because then they're out
in the public and you can see them
whereas indoors
you can't really enforce these these
laws um
so so it's a lot but but on the other
hand i understand that it's it's not so
easy to
to control that people are following
these measures but it's important to
make sure that everyone understands that
really indoors that's where which can
get dangerous
thank you so much for your insight
christoph asback president of the
society
for aerosol research it was good to have
you with us
let's take a look at some other
developments in the pandemic now
in the u.s health authorities are
recommending an immediate pause in
administering the johnson and johnson
19 vaccine after six people developed
rare
blood clots within weeks of getting the
shot it comes a day after 55 million
doses of the jab started to be delivered
to the eu
india will fast track emergency
approvals for covet-19 vaccines that
have been authorized
by western countries and japan the
country is ramping up
its vaccine rollout efforts as it
battles soaring
infection rates and the director general
of the world health organization says
confusion
and complacency means the pandemic is a
long way from over
but proven public health measures could
bring it under control
within months
you